what's up guys we're confidency today
we're playing table tennis battleships
first ones pop all five balloons wins
let's go this is the first one so scary
last time I lost autumn yeah I'm smarter
this son of cause it all worked out
sound
are there any spare balloons because I
think I might what happened there I know
nothing oh no yeah next one you blow up
Emily you're not allowed to replace hi
this is the golden one
you will never pop this one keep your
eyes on this one cuz this one will make
it through the whole game alright so
that was a bit of an accident with the
balloon but you're back on track okay I
hope we are planted already
good luck ml good luck Mika oh this is
this is always so nervous this is this
yeah I'm not even gonna hit the table no
you don't hit the table
[Applause]
Oh novel shop it sounded like a gumbo
whoo
not even close Santa I think it was
quite close how am I not hitting them
that was actually really close was it he
bluffing or what I don't know that was
really close
[Music]
how does he know where my ball reads the
euro I actually think it's somewhere
it's it's a long one maybe yeah now
let's start popping him or not
and do you even have any balls over
there I might touch with some under the
table yes I got one I had to give you
one the square - Emma - Emma's right
right on the edge I didn't hit it did I
whoa
I feel that it's somewhere there buddy I
haven't just heated yeah I still think
it's in this corner owner of this phone
shop
[Music]
who's gonna hit this first
yes
cool okay you touched it yeah the second
time every bus that will really second
time I didn't do I get the pop from the
first one already okay you got that one
mo thanks whoa three one one more to go
I'm pretty sure it has to be a short one
and I think it's it's on the right side
too
I mean middle short
he's may be onto something no it's not
under the table Emma it's got to be long
far no nothing did it touch the vs. okay
okay well now I know where it is not
even close Emma oh that was a jackpot
that was a jackpot who definitely was a
jackpot
yeah okay okay okay now we're both down
to the last balloon so it's a perfect
time for you guys to get subscribe it's
down to the final balloon ever
[Music]
[Applause]
come on you know I found it you're
somewhere here in this one oh it was
that one yeah okay I hope you guys
enjoyed this balloon battle next time it
will be me against all the winners play
against each other until next time